on march 11 2015 a toddler was playing
on his family's five-acre farm when he
slipped into a freezing cold creek with
a strong current
by the time they found him he was a
quarter mile downstream
caught in the branch face down in 34
degree water
no pulse no brain function little cardel
martin was clinically dead
for all purposes intent he's dead he's
dead
there was no signs of life for an hour
and 41 minutes
and yet after 101 minutes of cpr
gardelle came back from the dead
as gardelle's body was slowly warm his
pulse and heart rate eventually returned
a recovery for the record books a few
days later gardelle was back with his
parents as if nothing happened
no visible signs of permanent damage the
duration of cpr
and the rapidity of the recovery and the
completeness of the recovery i think
those are the things that are
stand out is quite striking a true
miracle
or is it i just can't thank him enough
we feel very unworthy
and very grateful as it turns out the
freezing cold water he was in
put his body into a state of suspended
animation
his organs were in a state of protection
they had very little metabolic needs
when a person's body temperature drops
around 20 degrees or so
they can survive for a good amount of
time being clinically dead before being
brought back to life
events like these blur the lines between
our understanding of life
and death
and as baby boomers are inching ever so
closer to the grim reaper
the rich the powerful the intellectuals
of the bunch have started wondering
is death a requirement can we cure aging
or at least slow it down maybe even
reverse it
even though the quest for the fountain
of youth is as old as men today we do
have the money the technology and the
resources to possibly make a dent in the
problem
and in this video we're gonna cover the
different efforts happening around the
world right now
that are taking another swing at the
age-old pursuit of immortality
now some of you might be asking but why
would you want to live forever
and to that i will reply why would you
want to die
aging is not as romantic as they make it
out to be your golden years are more
like the most painful years of your life
they're filled with disease pain regrets
think about it what if einstein could
have lived another hundred years
what if elon musk didn't have to die for
another few centuries
what revolutionary ideas innovations and
ventures have been lost throughout
history because
death showed up too early every day we
are alive is a blessing a miraculous
gift
but every day those same gifts grow
smaller the sands of time dribble away
who enjoys watching the people they love
slowly with their way who likes it when
their old parents can't even remember
who they are
i definitely can't wait for that and
most importantly who would want to be
that person one day
if you want to be that person one day
well have fun
but for the rest of us death may be the
great equalizer
but who wants to be equal this is the
race against fates
[Music]
but first a question you love your cable
company right
just kidding cable is pretty terrible
fortunately there is an alternative
fubotv imagine if there was a way for
you to watch over a hundred of your
favorite tv channels like vice the
documentaries are actually good cnbc
ufc fights at half the cost of what
you're paying right now that's fubo tv
with fubo there's no cable box no
locking contracts and most definitely no
bs
stay tuned to the end to learn more or
try right now completely risk free
it takes just two minutes to sign up you
can cancel at any time and hell though
even notify you the day before your free
trial and so there are no surprises
so pause the video right now and go to
fubotv.com jake to claim your free 7-day
trial and 15 off your first month
that's foobotv.com jake
in sunny scottsdale arizona lies a
unique company called the alcor life
extension foundation
one of only four companies in the entire
world that specializes in what's called
cryonics
and for a surprisingly affordable price
of fifty dollars per month
plus a separate life insurance policy of
around two hundred fifty thousand
dollars
which comes out to around twenty five to
eight hundred dollars per month
depending on your age health etc so for
fifty dollars per month plus life
insurance
alcor will have a medical team for you
on standby and once that dreadful day
arrives when you're pronounced dead via
police a doctor an emt
how core will get notified they'll rush
a team out to your corpse
and then rush your corpse back to their
facility while they'll freeze your body
to a cool negative
degrees celsius from there they'll store
you in their secure freezer and then
it's what we call
the big weights in the middle of this
building is possibly the strangest and
most unsettling thing i've ever seen
a field of stainless steel tanks holding
the bodies
and heads of 170 dead people
they'll keep your body there until
hopefully one day we'll be able to
revive you back to life
kinda like the toddler gardel we talked
about earlier if you're looking for an
even more affordable option
they also offer what's called neuro cryo
preservations
which only require at least an eighty
thousand dollar insurance policy
unlike whole body coral preservations
with neuro cryo preservations
they only freeze your head the thinking
behind this is that if we advance to a
point where we can
reanimate bodies fabricating a new and
improved body should be child's play
so why take up all that extra real
estate when all the things that make you
you lie in your brain that would be the
neural can that the patient is
in and it of course has identification
on it
alcor has over 1300 members including
people like peter thiel
and 181 frozen patients also known as
one of them being the co-founder of
alcor himself fred chamberlain
my husband is in this doer right here
and so i come in every now and then say
hi fred
how you doing now freezing your dead
body may sound a little crazy
when i'm dead just throw me in the trash
but is it any more crazy than letting a
perfectly good slightly damaged corpse
rot six feet under
eric are you sure this is a good idea no
it's not a good idea
it's an awesome idea yeah i guess it is
see in animal experiments there's a
control animal and the experimental
animal
with cryonics you're the experimental
animal there's a chance you could be
reanimated
there's a chance you could remain dead
but at least there's a possibility
people who don't sign up for cryonics
are the control animals and we already
know what's gonna happen in them
they're all guaranteed to die and stay
dead
with that being said i'm probably gonna
sign up will you
let me know in the comments below the
problem with something like alcor is
that it's more of a plan b
in case we don't cure aging in our
lifetime plan a is to not die in the
first place
so let's take a look at the visionary's
pioneering that front
before september 2013 the field of aging
and life extension was
pretty pathetic it was viewed as sort of
a fringe field
there was hardly any funding the
research was all over the place and it
tended to attract
more eccentric characters and looser
scientific standards
but a man named bill morris was about to
change that stigma bill morris was the
head of google's venture capital fund
google ventures making him one of the
most successful vcs in silicon valley
and after having to watch his
grandmother waste away losing her mind
inch by inch
bill got to wondering why do people have
to die at all
so he pitched the idea of a startup
aimed at carrying aging to the google
co-founders larry page and sergey brin
and they loved it then he got art
levinson to lead the company
another silicon valley titan that the
general public doesn't really know about
levinson was the former chairman of
apple and the former ceo and chairman of
genentech
the very first biotech company that
revolutionized medicine he has a
doctorate in biochemistry over 80
scientific papers 11 patents and a ton
of awards
and on september 18 2013 google's new
mysterious company called calico
launched in an effort to manufacture
something that silicon valley has never
been able to make
time calico is short for the california
life company but also references a cat's
nine lives
why does google really care about
extending life
and aging i think google is interested
in
some of the very large societal problems
and aging is one of those problems
that society is going to be facing more
and more over the coming years the
number of people over the age of 65
by in a couple years will exceed the
number of people under the age of five
and the care for people as they get
older and as they get sick the costs are
just
mounting both to themselves to their
families into society so how can we
allow people to live healthier this was
the catalyst the aging field needed
for the first time it wasn't some tiny
government study that was tackling aging
but google
with their very deep pockets backing it
and with the all-star silicon valley
team and 1.5 billion dollars in funding
it gave the field some real credibility
and the money started flowing in
since their founding silicon valley
millionaires and billionaires have
started dumping billions into other
immortality startups
with some estimates putting the market
at 20 billion dollars by 2025
and this new movement has led to some
remarkable advances in recent years
including the rise of one professor by
the name of david sinclair
who i like to think is kind of like the
poster boy for anti-aging
and if his research pans out he might
end up as a boy again
well we're literally reversing not just
the effects of aging but aging itself so
if i gave you
those retinas very little retinas here
you go joe and you're a scientist you
could
look at that retina and analyze it
molecularly measure its clock
and you'd say those are young young eyes
and you wouldn't know the difference
david sinclair's theory on why we age
has to do with damage to our epigenome
i'm going to try to explain this as
simply as possible basically all our
cells have the same dna
but how does a cell know to be an eye
cell versus a skin cell or what have you
that's where the epigenome comes in the
epigenome is how your dna is packaged
some parts of the dna are bundled up
with proteins to turn that section of
the dna
off and some sections of the dna are
left open spoiled out
or turned on to be read and how your dna
is packaged like this what parts are
turned on where parts are turned off the
epigenome
tells the cell what kind of cell it
should be and as time goes on your dna
gets naturally damaged by things like uv
lights
so your cells have to repair your dna
and get it back to how it was originally
packaged
it has to reset your epigenome this
works perfectly 99
of the time but that one percent where
the structure of your dna isn't reset
perfectly
that is the aging process according to
david sinclair
over time as the epigenome gets more and
more damaged
cells forget what kind of cells are
supposed to be and if you don't have the
epigenome
the skin cell will forget what type of
cell it is and it might turn into a
brain cell
which may not be that bad but if your
brain turns into a skin cell you've got
a problem
and i think that's largely what aging is
using this knowledge david sinclair has
been able to figure out ways to slow
down the damage to your epigenome
and thus slow down aging and by
intentionally damaging the epigenome
sinclair has also been able to speed up
aging
but what's even more crazy is that
sinclair has been able to figure out how
to reset the epigenome back to our
younger states
meaning that we're able to reverse aging
altogether for a group of cells
and now he's working on how to reverse
the age of the entire body as we speak
that's the future that you'll get a
delivery of this virus you'll take the
antibiotic for a few weeks
be fully rejuvenated and the doctor says
come back in a couple of decades we'll
fix you again and we'll give you some
antibiotic in a couple of decades
well there'll be a time when you can't
really tell how old somebody is
especially when we figure out how to
reprogram the body to be young again
[Music]
and then there's neurolink from elon
musk neural link is taking an entirely
different approach
instead of trying to cure aging head on
or freezing you after you die
neurolink's goal is to work around your
existing body and maybe even go beyond
the human body in the future
their reasoning is that while we're
researching how to cure aging why not
try to make the process of getting old a
little less dreadful by curing a lot of
the brain related diseases that come up
as a result of aging
that's where their brain machine
interface comes in a computer chip that
wires directly to your brain
since all brain diseases boil down to
electrical signals being sent in your
brain
neurolink's goal is not only read these
signals but to also send the right
signals to your brain to counteract
things like memory loss hearing loss
blindness paralysis depression strokes
and more
and their latest update in august 2020
has shown some great progress
they've been able to implant real chips
into the brains of pigs keep the pigs as
healthy as normal
and read and interpret the information
coming directly from the pig's brains
we've got a video breaking down their
latest entire update which will be
linked below and down the road as
neurolink is able to sync up with the
entire brain
transferring your consciousness to a
computer or a new body all of a sudden
doesn't seem that far off
doing so would eliminate the need for
curing aging
i can altogether you one thing if i had
all that time
[Music]
i sure as hell wouldn't waste it
[Music]
some say birth control was the biggest
biological revolution of our time
for the first time we had control over
such a deep rooted part of our survival
reproduction passing on our genes we
underwent a biological revolution in the
1950s
late 1950s with the emergence of the
birth control pill
and that for the first time in human
history gave women
pretty reliable control over their
reproductive function and that really
transformed them into entirely different
biological beings
solving immortality though the world has
witnessed big plays before
but what was bigger than death that
would top birth control a thousand-fold
and the repercussions would be
incomprehensible
both good and bad would we still have a
sense of purpose a sense of urgency if
we knew we really did have all the time
in the world
when forever comes will we be able to
survive it
no one can answer these questions right
now but what i do know is that i do
accept death as a possibility
but it's definitely not my first choice
do not go gentle into that good night
but until that day arrives where you can
live forever there are simple things you
can do right now to potentially extend
not just your lifespan but your healthy
lifespan
the problem is that a lot of them do
cost money but fear not because i do
have the solution foobo tv
by ditching your cable box and signing
up for fubu tv you can watch all the
shows that you love at half the cost of
what you're paying right now to your
cable company
and then you can use those savings to
fund things like extending your healthy
lifespan
with football tv you get instant access
to over 100 of your favorite channels
including complete coverage of all your
favorite sports plus you can record your
favorite games and shows on fubu tv's
cloud dvr
and watch it from anywhere on any device
i'm personally watching the show
billions right now which is absolutely
amazing
and exclusively available on show time
one of the many channels you can
instantly access with your fubu tv
subscription
so cut your cable bill in half in just
two minutes by going to fubotv.com
jake to claim your free 7-day trial and
15 off your first month
you have nothing to lose and you get to
support the brands that help make this
channel possible
the link is on the screen and in the
video description below
so would you want to live forever
especially if you had like the same
health
and fitness and agility that you have in
like your 20s and 30s
in your hundreds people are usually like
passionately
for or against this so let me know what
you guys think in the comments below
i for one obviously want to live forever
because there's just still
too much to learn and do and all that
stuff not enough time the anti-aging
field is like as cutting edge as it gets
there's always new research coming out
and
a ton of stuff that i didn't get to
mention so if i did miss something
let me know in the comments below this
is something that i am truly passionate
about so if you guys want more videos on
it just let me know in the comments and
i will gladly make more
if you are new to this channel and you
want more videos like this we make them
every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world of
business just like this video so hit
that subscribe button
and that notification bell if you want
behind the scenes stuff and day in life
kind of stuff
and all that other crap you can follow
me on instagram jaketrend.io that's
going to wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you